[Música]
agora esqueçam tudo
esqueça seu trabalho
esqueça a sua profissão sua carreira
esqueça os seus amigos sua família
imagina que você nasceu aqui hoje
agora todo seu passado toda essa
história de vida imaginei que não tem
nada o que você faria se você nascer se
hoje com a profissão qual carreira qual
caminho nessa jornada da vida você
levaria então essa pergunta foi feita a
mim há sete anos atrás e mudou toda a
minha vida eu trabalhava no tribunal de
justiça do maranhão era formado em
psicologia era concursada do tribunal de
maranhão trabalhei lá há cinco anos e
vara de família cartório de família
digitando alvará há documentos o juiz
pensão alimentícia aquele trabalho bem
estável
o sonho de muitos né aquele trabalho que
você tenha aposentadoria garantida mas
dentro de mim eu estava explodindo
eu sempre gostei de criar e eu não podia
usar nenhuma criatividade nem mudar a
fonte dos documentos tinha que ser times
new roman
então acho que como uma forma de fuga
lhe daquele trabalho tão burocrático eu
eu gosto de encher o bucho dos amigos né
então eu peguei um dia fiz uma
limpadinha cvp serviço
aí o pessoal que março empada de hot dog
de pizza traz amanhã aids a gente amanhã
não vai dar tempo em que toda a gente
paga os ingredientes traz aí que a gente
tá bom
aí eu comecei a levar aí o pessoal do
cartório do lado começou a sentir o
cheiro traz pra gente também
aí o corredor já se usava empada né aí o
pessoal do corredor traz pra gente
também e aí eu comecei a vender no
corredor e e quando eu vi já estava
vendendo pré de tudo e depois já estava
com uma maleta assim o andando corredor
todo com uma maleta cheia de empada era
4min paga por mês
o cartório da lavra ímpar da secretaria
chegou já está demais já está virando
uma lanchonete não era as partes que
estava no balcão e os advogados já eram
as os clientes querem fazer pizza de
carnes ao creme de macaxeira e aí eu já
estava já tinha funcionário e dois
funcionários contratados revendedores eu
já tava microempresário em seis meses
e aí os clientes começaram a pedir a
gente quer um ponto das empadas a gente
quer ir lá para poder comprar lâmpadas e
tá bom então vamos preparar as empadas
quero mais esse é o nome da empresa e aí
eu fiz um curso preparatório para
microempreendedores e nesse curso é essa
pergunta foi posta mim onde você queria
está imagine que você não tem nada eu
esqueci nós que ser limpados esqueci o
tribunal o concurso meu pai e minha
família meus amigos o que achava de
largar o concurso e pela primeira vez eu
consegui claramente ver a ana o que que
eu quero da minha vida e não que as
pessoas que eram o que talvez mais certa
a fazer e aí ficou tão claro o meu deus
a minha vida toda eu fiz o que joguei
videogame a minha vida toda sempre em
todos os momentos da minha vida o
videogame estava presente
meus melhores amigos eu fiz foi jogando
videogame
eu até tive um campo profissional de
counter strike
então eu refleti pela primeira vez em
mim e me deu a um espaço de pensar o que
eu quero da minha vida ana o que eu
quero fazer da minha vida daqui em
diante
e aí foi um momento que deu uma
reviravolta na minha vida começou a vida
do zero eu chutei mesmo foi o pau da
barraca
eu larguei o concurso público peguei o
dinheiro das empadas que eu tinha pedir
o carro e bola pra frente todo mundo
pessoal está doido do dc ó vai largar o
emprego concurso público fazer o quê
videogame
aí você imagina isso lá no maranhão se
até hoje idéia
é um pouco estranho você dizer que tá na
carreira de videogame é um pouco novo
você imagine só sete anos atrás do
maranhão que nem curso de game tem ainda
então eu peguei com a cara ea coragem
foi na internet mesmo ali procurei a
china a europa um curso abrirá fazia já
falava inglês que eu aprendi jogando
videogame
e aí eu encontrei um curso na inglaterra
e eu fui para lá nem sabendo eu queria
ficar morando lá há seis anos da minha
vida fiz um ano de programação em games
meu primeiro curso imagina que eu não
sabia nada a gente não sabia nem o que
era ser mais mais sem menos - eu nunca
tinha perdido em photoshop e aí eu
comecei do zero
meu primeiro curso foi de programação em
games e depois desse curso eu descobri
que eu poderia fazer uma estrada em
games por causa do curso de psicologia e
eu consegui ingressar no mestrado também
lá na inglaterra que foram dois anos
eu sou hoje eu sou mestre dos games e lá
o curso eram dois anos e o segundo ano
você tinha um ano todo para fazer o seu
projeto final de mestrado que é um game
que você leva um evento e apresenta ao
público
e aí quando eu tive aí eu tive que tinha
que ter essa idéia para criar o jogo
demorou um pouco mas eu tive um sonho
que eu estava jogando videogame na
televisão e aí o jogo começou de empatar
os gráficos bem é iniciantes e aí os
gráficos foram melhorando ea sala todo o
meu redor pixelado ao meu redor
até o momento que os gráficos do jogo
ficaram tão realistas que a sala onde
estava o jogo estavam todos juntos e eu
acordei e o pc essa idéia eu vou fazer
um jogo sobre a minha história de vida e
como eu joguei dois jogos de videogame
acompanhei toda essa evolução que
aconteceu nos anos 80 que não vai
acontecer de novo e devia jogar um jogo
você jogava mário sonho que você quer
ver como é que aquele personagem vai
ficar no próximo videogame você vê a
tarde mega da vis toda aquela explosão
que teve
e aí eu acabei criando pixel gripe que é
um jogo sobre a minha vida
você está jogando o jogo em 1989
só que você está na sala de aula e você
tem que esconder o jogo da professora
para você completar aquele jogo é como
se fosse um jogo dentro do jogo e aí foi
engraçado que quando a primeira idéia
veio na minha
na minha cabeça sobre o jogo o design é
tão claro vai ser um personagem
masculino
claro é um gamer né eu nem me toquei
ahmed diretor conversando comigo fala
assim porque você não faz uma personagem
feminina as idéias vão fluir bem melhor
aí eu troquei coloquei a protagonista
feminina e aí de repente as idéias
começaram a fluir
aí eu comecei a colocar toda a minha
experiência eu minha história de vida de
crescer jogando videogame nos anos 80 eo
jogo foi feito desde o começo para a
realidade virtual
aí você imagina que isso é 2014 quando
não tinha quase nada é até hoje é um
oceano azul já está sendo explorada
realidade virtual e aí eu coloquei o
jogo na no site do óculos rift quem não
conhece que agora o facebook comprou ó
cruzando os headsets de realidade
virtual mais conhecidos e lá na época
não tinha uma loja ainda tinha um site
que todo mundo mundo todo colocava lá os
aplicativos e jogos e colocavam lá no
site
e aí o jogo alcançou o primeiro lugar no
ranking mundial e foi uma coisa
inesperada eu pensei um projeto
universitário vou colocar lá e conseguir
no máximo emprego e aí eu sou o primeiro
lugar mundial e viu o youtube começaram
a pegar o jogo jogado 10 milhões de
views no total
e aí a imprensa começou a me procurar e
aí os investidores começaram a entrar em
contato e aí a empresa diz não tem presa
ainda então vou abrir e aí eu voltei
novamente o que é ser empreendedor
mas agora na área certa e aí eu abri a
empresa pixel gripe e aí eu acabei indo
para o vale do silício
lá no vale do silício eu consegui
investimento mil óculos mesmo investir
no jogo no começo lá no vale do silício
fiz uma aceleradora e aí continuei
trabalhando no projeto já estava há um
ano e meio morando lá até que dois meses
atrás acabei voltando pro brasil
uma empresa que a árvore né que está
agora trabalhando só tocando com
experiência imersiva realidade virtual e
realidade aumentada a gente está fazendo
uma parceria para completar o jogo
terminar e lançar junto ano que vem
então é interessante ver que mesmo
quando a gente pensa que a decisão a ser
tomada na vida é um pouco tardia poderia
ter pensado não devo mudar agora deve
continuar meu trabalho já estou lá
estava
mas você pensa vou começar tudo do zero
aprender tudo diferente será que vai dar
tempo será que eu não estou a fazer não
é mas é interessante você vê que quando
você tem um foco certo você não está
perdida atirando para todos os lados
você tem uma paixão uma coisa que você
sabe pra onde você quer chegar
tudo flui e até esses cursos que eu
pensei que eu não quero usar psicologia
e tipo inglês que aprendi jogando
videogame foi tudo se encaixando e tudo
foi andando até a experiência que eu
tive administrando as empadas que eu
achei que me usar
acabou me ajudando muito pra chegar a
levar o pixel hips é um produto eu
sempre vi esse jogo como um produto
justamente pela visão empreendedora que
eu tinha quando fazem paradas de hot dog
adquirir carne de sol
então é bom que mesmo que a gente tome a
decisão de trocar de mudar de vida
começar do zero que venha porque você
vai ver que por linhas tortas meio que
não tradicionais você chega no lugar
até hoje me pergunto todos os dias
se eu voltasse eu nascesse hoje onde eu
queria está e eu fico muito feliz de
saber que eu estaria fazendo exatamente
a mesma coisa que eu estou fazendo hoje
e eu queria agora passar para vocês essa
pergunta onde você gostaria de estar se
você não sei se hoje aqui agora você
está exatamente onde você está obrigada
[Aplausos]